thank you
well hey everybody it's Sunday yeah and
uh yeah I don't have my tablet I left it
in there he just realized that I was
just like I feel like I'm going I feel
like I don't like I'm going bareback
without it
like I don't have much protection I know
right you need to well I don't know what
the hell's going on in the comment
section I don't even see a comment
section well I can read them to you
though like I can read them to you but I
believe Jen the ultimate responsibility
of telling me what the comments are okay
because uh how many people we got in
there well I don't know I've told you a
million times I can't there's no there's
no count on this you can't see it oh
there it is there it is I can't see
there's somebody saying something that's
Santa and Santa yeah that's why it's
appropriate that you're the first one
here because you were the one that sent
us this movie that's right and thank you
very much for sending this because I
enjoyed this quite a bit and Tom
actually really dug it oh yeah xanadas
sent this to us uh through Amazon Prime
it arrived hard copy
this this if you don't have this movie
all right you should own this movie if
you like gangster movies
that that's up there with I think it's a
little bit better than Scarface if you
ask me I think well I haven't seen
Scarface in a lot I think so I'm not I
haven't seen in a long time but it's
almost I think I think I
I remember I like this more better than
how I remember the Scarface I have to
see it again but nah I think it's better
to Scarface there's something about it
it's kind of got a well first of all I
shot really well the director is [__]
really good
and I think the cinematographer got some
kind of award for this too a lot of uh
it's kind of dark with colors uh it's
got a horror movie [__] vibe to it uh
tonally it's real good it's kind of dark
um even though it has action sequences
in it and I'd seen this before
uh in the 90s sometimes and I didn't
remember the action sequences I remember
this being a movie with a lot of
dialogues kind of like something out of
The Godfather but no it had it has good
action in it man so many people get shot
in this movie yeah so many yeah
it's got Chase scenes a lot of cool guns
a lot of cool 90s guns yeah you said you
said you were gonna check the uh the gun
database yeah maybe a movie gun database
yeah I really kind of didn't have to it
was uh uh [__] look like a chrome I
don't think it was stainless it looked
like a chromed um routing high power
with Target sights on it pack my grips
that's what Christopher Walken was
carried his last name was white right
was his name Frank White Frank White
yeah he's a great character in it he had
that uh they get attacked by some cops
they're uh that were
dressed up as bad guys they tried to
dress themselves up as criminals but
they were actually cops
um they attacked him with a bunch of
[__] custom AR-15s that was a pretty
good short barrel to AR-15s like xm177
styles
Gods it just just cool Gods cool guns uh
you know
the old school cop had it down five shot
Smith and Wesson
uh [__] 38 Special revolver you know
j-frame which is good you know
appropriate guns for the time and and
and the story it's it's in New York so a
lot you don't see a lot of exotic [__]
but
when the cops show up and pretended to
be a gag they had good [__] [__]
AR-15s and stuff
just uh and the story is good and the
interior shots are good it's almost kind
of like it has like an old [__]
Batman feel to it or something too
had a quote from the movie they're for
the they're for the bullet holes put
that yeah yeah that was a part of the
suitcase full of tampons that was
[__] great all-star cast holy [__] I
can I I don't think that I ever saw this
movie because Richard Brown points out
yeah this is Abel Ferreira and the thing
about it is that I had kind of heard of
this movie but I don't think I'd ever
seen it and then when it first started
we were watching it last night and Tom's
like wow this movie looks fantastic and
I was like look at this [__] cast man
holy crap it's like Christopher Walken
and Lawrence Fishburne and Wesley Snipes
and Steve Buscemi and yeah like there's
just all these really big like uh David
Caruso is in it yeah this is back in
1990 this came out and then like he was
he's like oh I'm really digging this
movie already and then director came up
I was like oh it's Abel Ferreira and I
was like he made Miz 45 which is
probably is probably my favorite movie
of his
um which we reviewed probably a couple
years ago he also did the driller killer
which I reviewed on flickers of fear
probably a few months back
um and after this movie he made Bad
Lieutenant with Harvey Keitel I remember
seeing it like which I really liked a
lot I've been wanting to know about it
I've been wanting to review that
actually because we haven't done that
one yet yeah Abel Ferreira is kind of
like he's kind of like scuzzy Scorsese
you know what I mean he's like because
he's like the quintessential like scuzzy
New York filmmaker if you all want us to
do Bad Lieutenant you send us to send us
a Blu-ray we'll move it to the front of
the we'll move it to the front of the
line uh I remember liking it when I saw
it when it came out I remember liking it
but I forgot everything about the movie
except the [__] famous scene of
Harvey Keitel as a cop pulling over the
[__] two teenage girls in the [__]
car making them [__] do kinky [__]
while he's beating it yeah on the side
of the road that was some [__] that
was a wild scene I remember that the
other [__] I didn't really we definitely
need to do that movie
[Laughter]
saw this movie
and I either I forgot everything about
it or I only saw a piece of this movie
because it seemed brand new and I was
watching it I was like some of it seemed
familiar certain scenes but in other
[__] I just
I didn't remember at all so it could be
that I only saw pieces of this movie it
came out in 1990 I would have been in
the service
during the time that I saw this this
might have been something that they were
playing in a rec room
that I got to see a little bit of it but
then they called me out to go do
something else
but seeing its entirety
on Blu-ray on a big [__] HD
television
it's like an old school Movie experience
they don't make movies like this anymore
and I think as far as I'm aware I think
this only costs five million dollars to
make yeah which only five million five
million yeah it's only five million you
never know which which that was a big
budget for Abel Ferreira you know what I
mean um but I think he went on later to
do like some more and he went into TV
and stuff as well but what was the trip
is before this movie started
the Blu-ray had a bunch of uh trailers
on it yeah and they had a Jason Statham
flick man playing us oh I got to see
that what was the name of that movie
crank crank and it's weird because when
because we saw the trailer for that yeah
and I was like this is so weird I was
like this is like some weird
synchronicity or something I was like I
was just reading an article about a
completely unrelated movie and somebody
in the comments mentioned that movie
crying and I had never seen it and it
was just really weird that like
literally the next day we saw like a
trailer for it like on another
completely unrelated movie yeah so I
thought that was pretty strange it
looked good that looked like a lot of
fun yeah yeah
somehow Jason states of his character
gets poisoned and he's got to keep his
adrenaline running I think he's working
for an organized crime it's kind of like
speed if Jason Statham was the bus yeah
he can't stop getting in trouble or have
a danger he'll die he's got to get in
all this that sounds like your fantasy
yeah sounds like me on on a [__] trip
come on yeah
yeah he's gonna be jumping on airplanes
and [__] like that yeah xanadas said
crank is great I'll have to send that
okay yeah yeah because he was like oh
man I need to see this I want to see Bad
Lieutenant too so yeah we get somebody
sent us Bad Lieutenant I'm gonna do that
one too and Tammy said oh yeah I
remember crank really good movie it
looks like a lot it looked good man it
looked real good it looked like a lot of
fun well it's really I think it's
because this um the the DVD or the
Blu-ray of King of New York came out in
2012. so I think that's why we were
seeing mostly
um previews for movies that came out
from like 2007 to 2012 you know what I
mean because this movie is old Fargo
that [__] was [__] far that was good
and then he sent this one this is
[__] I thought Louie sent Fargo or
was it loose so far I thought Sandra San
Fargo no xanador said Fargo oh okay
because uh he lived up up north where
that was
he lived up where that was uh filmed so
he wanted to see it but he said that was
Louis that training day that's right
yeah yeah we got them both like around
the same time yeah I think I think
xanador also said was it No Country For
Old Man I think you sent that too yeah
because I had been wanting to do that
movie for a long time
yeah he said I sent Fargo and no country
yeah yeah and then he said this one this
one [__] knocked it out of the park
this is a great flick this is out of the
three that he sent I like this one the
best even though they were all excellent
movies this one I got this one yeah this
is definitely right up here uh right in
your wheelhouse yeah it's got some good
gangster morality in there and about
yeah that's what you should do you know
what I mean yeah that's like yeah like
Christopher Walken the thing about in a
lot of able Ferrero movies forever
movies are like this where the you know
the morality is just very
gray yeah
um and Christopher Walken he's not the
good guy
um but he's not the worst dude in it
he's you know he's obviously a gangster
and he kills people in Cold Blood and
[__] like that or he has people killed
in Cold Blood they deserve it though but
yeah and he even kind of says that
toward the end so it's kind of like I'm
you know the cops don't want to hear it
obviously but he does actually have I
mean at the beginning of the movie he
gets out of prison I don't think they
say how long he was in jail but they
said it was yeah he said it was half his
life so I'm presuming it was about 30
years so I'm presuming it was a very
long time
um but when he comes out he's still got
presumably like all his money and his
gang is still there and all that kind of
stuff
in prison didn't mean that that stretch
was half of his life that's what I was
saying five and another five and a ten
you know that's what I was thinking I
didn't think that it had been like half
his life just this time around because I
said some of those people in his gang
like you still remembered him yeah yeah
it would wouldn't have been around
sounds like if he had been in prison
that long fish burn kind of co-stars in
this flick yeah all right and this was
one of his very early because he's
pretty young yeah he's pretty young and
uh
a lot of guys didn't know that he was an
Apocalypse Now too he was clean the
young kid who gets that's right he was
the machine gunner yeah I think we
mentioned that on the yeah that's really
Lawrence Fishburne's first role that I I
know if he was yeah he went by Larry
Fishburne actually he went by Larry
Fishburn in this movie so like he
changed it Lawrence is kind of cooler it
is cooler but he he does a great job he
he really shines in this
so does Snipes Snipes [__] does a
good job in this too but I think out of
the two they both did a great job but uh
Lawrence Fishburn [__] shines in this
one Jimmy jump that's a simple character
yeah and he's a supporting character
but he's a major supporting character
he's kind of like the other good guy on
the [__] in the gags and he's a gangster
but he's he's kind of like
Christopher Walken's uh character's
right hand man yes uh [__]
he's Frank White's like right hand man
me and just cool [__] happens in the
flick you just gotta see it and
white does have
some redeeming qualities I mean his his
part of New York has fallen apart and
they're shutting the hospital down yeah
I think they say it's South Bronx yeah
and I think it was kind of like a free
Hospital
and um
one of the things that he's doing with
his money is he wants to fund that
hospital to keep it open
yeah because it's just poor people go
there he's trying to like go legitimate
and he does seem to have like I said he
does seem to have like a moral code
because one of the reasons that he wiped
I could because when he gets out of jail
and he reconnects with his gang and he's
still got all his money because he's
essentially you know very wealthy and
kind of hobnobs with uh the elite and
whatnot is that
um he's immediately starts wiping out
rival gangs well at first he gives them
like an opportunity to like join him or
or let him get in on the [__] like on in
on the action whatever big drug deals
are doing or whatever but if they refuse
he's like yeah I'm just gonna like
[__] rub you out and all of your
people unless you want to join me so he
starts doing that which obviously is
good because it eliminates the
competition but also he says later on
that he's like you know a lot of those
dudes were doing not only just drug
trafficking stuff like that but also
human trafficking like we're pimping out
13 year old girls [__] like that so it's
like you know and he's like and I don't
want people to yeah he's a criminal too
but he didn't want he's like I'm not
gonna make money that way yeah um you
know selling drugs okay but he's not
gonna be doing like he said that's not
my problem right his drug problem that's
your guys's problem right the cops yeah
yeah that's the thing well he was saying
that America was asking for these drugs
so that's not his problem that's that's
their problem their customers yeah I
mean there was a demand
it wasn't him yeah
um but no it's a good flick it's a real
good flick yeah he goes out and wipes
out
well
the criminals had taken over his area
he does try to get him to to to come on
board when he's down he just wipes them
out yeah he makes them an offer like hey
wipe out all their men though yeah like
one dude he just said something sideways
to him in a table and turned right
around just instantly killed him bam he
goes you guys are sick wasting your
money you're following pieces of [__]
like this and just like meet me at the
hotel over here and you know we'll set
all this right and um dudes were just
like oh okay you know but I don't think
that was Italian mafia yeah guys joined
up with him but I don't think they went
after him either right
because I never saw that guy again or no
did they did they join
oh they might have you know because they
might have been in that Hideout where
they were keeping the the drugs that
they stole from a Chinese guys right
yeah that yeah that was then he also
wiped out a bunch of the Triad dudes
yeah the Chinese guys he killed them all
yeah they wouldn't uh I forgot what it
was that they wouldn't do they wouldn't
they wouldn't let him distribute I think
is what it was right he wanted to
distribute the stuff
they wouldn't let him do it so he just
killed him and took their [__] yeah it's
funny because Zachary as soon as you
said uh I'll wear your big glasses Jenny
you look different without them I only
just realized that I didn't have the big
glasses on I had the best they're right
there yeah well I had the littler ones
on because they're a hit man I don't
usually wear the big ones just around I
like these but they don't magnify these
are my favorite yeah I can't see in
those yeah just show show them those
yeah those are cute well yeah I can see
them show them these These are actually
my favorite ones but they're not they're
not magnifying yeah like I said I can't
see like in these because they're just I
want to get her somewhere just glasses I
think you'll see everything is just
blurry yeah I think those are cuter but
what I was saying was that um I don't
wear the big ones just around because
they tend to like slide down my nose and
stuff like that like so I don't like to
wear them like long periods of time I
can adjust all that but um you know so I
had the littler ones on and I totally
forgot like what and I just realized it
like a second before I read your comment
which I thought was like really funny
um xanadas said I love when Fishburn and
Snipes get in the shootout and Fishburne
laughs like a maniac after being shot
that is [__] great
um he was a real psychopath yeah and the
limo scene at the funeral is a classic
as well uh yeah and um I honestly was
not expecting that but so I really liked
that scene I also really liked the scene
where there was like that car chase and
it was the um you know the cops that
were it wasn't all the cops it was David
Caruso and and Wesley Snipes and a
couple of the other dudes and they said
you know we're gonna pretend to be a
rival gang essentially and take Frank
White out because obviously he's just
using his lawyer and using his money and
stuff like that to get away with [__]
and they were like a little bit
resentful about it
so uh so they do that and then like this
whole car chase ensues and one of the
dudes Who ah man the actor was like so
familiar and I just couldn't like
[__] place him but he was the dude
that got married like early on in the in
the movie and he was hanging on the side
of the car like while they're and they
just ran him into a [__] fire hydrant
it was like smush and I was just kind of
like [__] man oh it's just like the
thought of it was like and then he's
like he's all [__] up and broken like
all this [__] but yeah so David Caruso
gets his [__] head blown off like at
a funeral which I was not expecting that
at all
but he was like such a douche in this
movie David Caruso like you can
understand you can understand both sides
of it yeah the cops are gonna be mad
because it's like dude like obviously
this dude is a criminal and they're
trying to they're doing their job catch
him yeah and it's like and it was
frustrating for them because you know
they'd get him on something or they you
know they arrested like um Lawrence
Fishburne's character and we're trying
to get him to roll over and stuff like
that but they just went and got him out
and so they're like look the dude is
just laughing at us and just walking all
and just getting away with all this crap
and meanwhile his girlfriend was a good
attorney yeah and uh it was his it was
his main lawyer and he had a lot of
money but don't really explain where he
got his money from I guess he had it
stashed but when he gets out of prison
he's already got money yeah and uh so
guys on his team would get arrested for
murder and stuff and they get bonded
right back out
and be on the street the next day and
they could fight stuff so you know yeah
if it's doing what organized criminals
do right I mean you have that kind of
money and those kind of connections
because it was kind of hinted too that
he had like larger political connections
right because there was that like at the
beginning he was going to that dinner
with some of those people that I was
presuming were kind of powerful yeah
whatever
you know what I mean they keep a lot of
stuff big in the movie yeah like where
his money came from yeah I mean I'm
presuming because he was so well known
that you know he'd been like a big drug
kingpin yeah prior to him going to
prison so he had it all hidden he had it
all hidden somewhere or like I said he'd
maybe put it in
you know they have all kind of ways
around that where you can like put it in
some kind of trust or some kind of thing
it's like maybe his his girlfriend or
the woman he was [__] I don't really
know if he'd call her girlfriend but
um he was his girlfriend yeah she was a
little match going on they just don't
really introduce that character they
don't give her much to do yeah it's kind
of like a accessory yeah she was like an
attorney and um she was based so I guess
she knew like all the legal loopholes
and all that other kind of crap like the
way to keep him at a well she obviously
didn't keep him out of prison because he
went to prison but like where his money
went and stuff like that and when it's
able to you know get everybody else out
when they were in trouble
says Christopher Walken was on the
sailboat when Natalie Wood died near
Catalina Island yeah that's right I
think we did a show we didn't do a show
just about Natalie Wood but I think we
did a show about
um like Hollywood
you know messed up stories from
Hollywood and I think we talked about
that on there but yeah Christopher
Walker and Anthony Perkins
um we're best friends they grew up
together in a circus evidently
Anthony Perkins as in from psycho okay
yeah because I know sometimes I get
confused their parents were carnies or
something right really yeah I didn't
really when they were kids
I don't know how to look more into that
that's actually pretty interesting
Christopher walk-in I mean
this he'd been in a bunch of movies
prior to this obviously he'd been in you
know he was in the deer hunter didn't he
get like an Oscar nomination for that or
am I thinking of someone else I think I
think there was some Oscars the deer
hunter was really good which that's
another movie we haven't done I don't
think and you know obviously he was in a
dead zone and yeah he was in some other
stuff too but this I kind of feel like
this movie was
almost like Peak walking you know what I
mean maybe that's kind of hard to say
because he's such a distinctive I don't
know man he some of the roles he can do
they're pretty like he in Dogs of War
that was another good movie he played a
mercenary
he does a lot of yelling in Dogs of War
he's kind of like the most unsoldierly
mercenary I've ever seen but he's it's a
good character though yeah he can get
away with it just because he's so he's
weird he's weird yeah yeah but he's
weird and like a really appealing kind
of way
he can just totally get away with
anything like you know the the [__]
weird like kind of hip-hop dancing he
does in this yeah yeah
yeah which I have to say this was nice
yeah and getting an anal probed by
aliens and whatnot but by a [__]
Electrolux vacuum cleaner hose
yeah we're gonna suck that right out of
there but um
what does it suck out nobody knows it's
just because whatever's in there
whatever's in there it's just weird [__]
man sucking some stuff out of here what
was that movie about what were they
thinking when they made it we were
wondering the LSI too because every time
well now every time we see someone with
Christopher walking in it we can't help
but like think about communion because
we were just like what the [__] was up
with that movie that was like the
weirdest [__] movie ever it's not
like the weirdest movie ever but it's
just tonally it was just kind of very
strange it was like all over the place I
think they were trolling us maybe
or at least I think I don't think the
director was trolling us but I
definitely think Christopher Walken yeah
he's trolling you through them that's
what I think made the whole thing so
strange because I think that I think the
director was taking it seriously and
Christopher Walken was absolutely not
but the director was too clueless to
know that Christopher Walken was like
making a joke out of it that's kind of
the impression I got I'm not really sure
if that's what happened but um
Cheng said his guys gave him that
Briefcase full of Cash when he got out
oh okay see I had totally forgotten
about that about that
dude I was paying attention
I wasn't that drunk so they had it
stashed somewhere okay yeah
yeah
um wasn't Christopher Walken a child
model oh I don't know
I kind of now that you mentioned it I
thought I heard somebody say about that
I don't really know about that and Zach
said he won for that movie The Deer
Hunter I'm assuming yeah yeah
um Xander says my dad says you guys
would like at close range with Sean Penn
and Christopher Walken I remember liking
that movie but I only saw it once and it
was like a long time I don't know like
probably only like a year or two after
it came out funny thing is is I've heard
from people who know Christopher Walken
it was what's his next his best friends
like belker I think his name is like a
comedian Richard Belzer yeah Belzer
that's Richard Belzer how did I pull
that out of mine yeah he would tell
stories about Christopher Walken and
Christopher Walken's kind of um
kind of dumb evidently he's kind of he's
he's real evidently kind of shallow and
uh goofy he's not real serious like like
he comes off in the movies he's supposed
to be kind of
he comes off as like a weird combination
of serious and Goofy at the same time
because he does some goofy [__] in this
movie too like the weird dances that he
does and yeah and all that kind of [__]
and like some of the stuff that he says
but then like he's also like in other
scenes he's like really really cold and
really scary Belzer likes him [__]
hangs out they're like best buddies but
he he just says he tries to get tell him
something deep you know certain ideas
and he said well you know he he can't
absorb anything very deep he's very
superficial
care about anything he's just like yeah
it was like smooth as like some like a
frozen lake in Minnesota bounces right
off he doesn't give a [__]
Zach says oh Richard Belzer he died like
last week actually did he really all
right holy [__] I just thought he was
like really funny they hung out
evidently yeah they were like the best
buds yeah enough where Belzer could make
fun of him right you know I feel like
Christopher Walken probably has a pretty
good sense of humor about himself yeah
he said he's [__] funny that he's
funny you probably have to like because
yeah I'm sure I'm sure he's a [__]
riot he seems like he'd be a [__]
right he said he's funny but he's kind
of like an airhead he doesn't want to
know anything deep or anything
complicated so you just like go out and
have a good time yeah yeah yeah she's
trying to talk politics yeah he didn't
he doesn't give a [__] about anything
well yeah I understand that but you know
you couldn't talk you couldn't talk
science or technology right or ideas and
no no pizza you know yeah
maybe it's not so much being dumb it's
just like I don't even want to get
involved with that kind of situation I
just want to have a good time and enjoy
my life yeah yeah
right so that's not necessarily being
dumb might be a smart way it might be a
smart that's what I'm saying he sounds
pretty smart to me yeah just ignore it
all
Santa said I love the dances he does in
this movie right I mean they're so
[__] funny I was gonna say that so
this movie came out in 1990 this was it
wasn't the first movie but I kind of
feel like this was one of the first
movies to feature like an almost all
hip-hop soundtrack because this was like
1990 that was a long time ago and that
wasn't really something because this was
before like New Jack City and all that
kind of stuff like that came out in the
you know in the early to mid 90s when it
became like kind of a big thing so this
was one of the I don't think this was
the first one to do it but it wasn't
hip-hop old retro right right right but
you don't notice it because it's just
incidental music mostly it's just the
music they're playing at the parties in
the background what's in the car and you
know it kind of it fits it doesn't it
doesn't it's not like it's been
shoehorned in there yeah it's very much
like of tonally like
well because that's what kind of like a
lot of his gang or yeah most of his most
was gang or black guys and the thing and
I kind of feel like too in the even
though this movie I've it got like
pretty okay reviews like when it came
out but it's I don't think it did like
all that well you know I think it made
money but not really all that much and
it sort of got like forgotten about but
for some reason
um it has like a big following it's like
in in hip-hop like it's been sampled
like in a lot of songs and stuff like
that because and I was even watching
earlier um like this one channel it was
like uh what is it hood movies or
something like that and that guy was
talking about although he didn't really
like it all that much but I do think
that a lot of there's uh a lot of
hip-hop artists and stuff like that are
really like into this movie and like
sampled it and stuff that's what the
tone of this movie is good
it just it's got a good dark tone it's
like a Neo Noir almost yeah like a Neo
Noir almost and they're living in these
hideouts that are on the outside look
like damn Gothic ruins and then you go
inside and it's kind of like
like a like a like an Italian gangster
Palace kind of like super opulent yeah
opulent looking but it's like dark you
know
almost Candlelight lit and just fire and
stuff there may not be electricity in
these things I don't know but they're
opulent yeah they might be like squat
well I think it's interesting because
well Christopher Walken's character I
mean like I said he's hobnobbing with
like the elites so he's like up in these
like super fancy like sweets and
everything like that but everybody else
is just kind of in these hideouts
decadent looking sort of like I said
they may be squatting but it kind of
looks like a faded Splendor yeah it
looks like something out of Batman yeah
or or like a Blade Runner but more like
Batman actually right and uh you know
like they're up on the roof you know
they're overlooking the city and
looks like [__] stone walls next to
him and [__] ancient looking building
you know with uh canopy beds and [__]
chandeliers and [__] yeah like some
interview with the vampires
[Laughter]
drugs down in the big old [__]
barrels and stuff down down in the
basement and yeah because when that dude
was talking about all the drugs that he
had I'm like oh shirtle and I was like
oh okay that's so you know that's that's
fair he really does have a lot of drugs
in there just barrels and barrels of the
[__] yeah and they got all these like
high-end hookers following around and
walking around half nude [__] having
sex with them all
it's pretty cool you know gangster [__]
gangster [__] gangster [__] yeah and
they sh I mean Abel Ferreira like as he
usually does he shot almost all of this
like just in and around New York so it's
not I think the only thing that was a
set was um the Chinatown
shootout
um I guess he couldn't really get
permission to shoot there for whatever
reason they couldn't shoot there
um so I think they built a set there and
you can I you know not gonna lie you
can't tell it's a set because it looks a
little bit artificial but the rest of it
um was filmed all around and we pretty I
particularly like that shot because you
even made a comment too like where
they're filming Christopher Walken like
near the end of the movie like walking
out of the subway like just from from
like Between the Bars and it's yeah it's
like a really really good shot like one
of the last shots of the movie I was
saying that it kind of reminded me
visually of Batman like the old Batman
but actually I was wrong what it really
reminds me of now that I think about
more like the crow visually yeah yeah
the first one yeah it's just shot really
well
well you know like I said Abel Ferreira
is kind of known for I mean if you see
driller killer
um which was one of his real early films
I think he started out kind of more in
porn like he made a movie called Nine
Lives of a wet [__] or something like
that oh yeah which yeah you probably
like that
like prior to I don't remember when he
made that but I've never seen it but
driller killer which he actually also
starred in
um was they just shot it in these like
this scuzziest like New York you know
Apartments like imaginable might have
been his own apartment not entirely sure
but you know everybody's just like drug
addicts and scuzzy punk bands and you
know crappy grotty clubs with disgusting
bathrooms and like all this other kind
of stuff like back in the Heyday like
when New York all looked like that so
this has a little bit of that it's a
little bit Slicker you know what I mean
because it's 1990 and he had like a
bigger budget I guess so it's not quite
as
gorilla and uh you know Lorenz some of
his early stuff was looks like an
expensive movie to me but yeah well well
yeah but I mean this is one of the more
expensive movies that he made yeah
because if you see like I said if you
see driller killer it looks like it was
made for like you know a hundred dollars
but it's still a great movie though it's
not really what the thing about driller
killer and I talked about this on my
other thing is that I think a lot of
people think of it as a horror movie
which it kind of is because it's you
know he's going around killing people
the drill obviously but it's kind of
more like a dark psychological like
character study more than a straight
horror movie like they they marketed it
like a slasher but it's not a slasher
maybe not at all it's kind of like and
so I kind of feel like he's really into
exploring
these just the Seedy underbelly of the
city and all these people that are kind
of like lurking around down there and
they're
they're gray morality and stuff which
this one has a lot of as well like I
said because nobody in this is a good
person there's not a single but you know
but nobody is entirely evil either
really like some of the cops are good
some of the cops are terrible some of
the gangsters are cold-blooded and
terrible but some of them have redeeming
qualities you know what I mean it's just
like
um Richard Brown said have you seen Abel
ferreira's Body Snatchers movie I
haven't yet and I wanted to because we
were talking about
the the original like Invasion of the
Body Snatchers like the one from
whenever the 50s or whatever that came
out and then the Philip Kaufman one that
came out in the 70s which is like my
favorite that's pretty good too and yeah
I really like that version like because
there's been a bunch of versions of it
made and they made another one I think
with Nicole Kidman like in the 2000s it
was just called Invasion but I haven't
seen that one either but I had forgotten
that Abel Ferreira made a version of it
too like in the 90s and I've heard it's
actually like really good but I haven't
seen it yet but that's one that I want
to get around to
um
Danny Rowling said Frank White goes out
in this film the same way as Tom Cruise
goes out in collateral yeah yeah so I
guess so I didn't even think about that
yeah because that's the thing like even
though he seemed like he was
legitimately trying to help out the
community
um but it still like didn't really help
him in the end you know what I mean he
just still kind of died alone
so
but you know it's just one of those kind
of bleak
that's kind of Bleak New York movies
it's kind of just a gangster movie
that's kind of the way along yeah yeah
yeah Santa said you never really know if
Frank White is helping out the black
people in his gang or exploiting them
they all seem to love him though yeah I
mean he does really seem to Garner a lot
of loyalty they all waited for him to
get out like however long he was in
there and he's helping him is just that
was their job yeah that's that's what
they did
yeah I mean Lawrence Fishburne is really
great in this too I you could I guess
you could say because I will say that
his character is very
um I don't know very but it's pretty
over the top and it's kind of like your
stereotypical 90s black gangster you
know what I mean
um but he just he pulls it off it
doesn't really come across like a
character or anything like that he
actually comes across like a really good
character well he was he was moving up
in a world yeah making money yeah you
know and uh getting power running
running the gang you know it was
basically the lieutenant and even though
he was kind of a psycho he still had a
good side too because remember there was
that one scene in the in the place where
he was ordering the food and he gave
those little kids like money to play the
video games because they didn't have any
and his Nemesis was Wesley Snipes who
was the black guy who was the cop
so you know they didn't like each other
they were on different sides of the law
but they were kind of equivalents of one
another yeah so uh they killed each
other basically
yeah it's a good it's a good movie I
really I really did actually like that
scene because that was just so funny
like when he gets shot he's just laying
there like laughing like a [__] hyena
it's just hysterical
um they kind of neutralized each other
yeah well and the same thing happened
with Christopher Walken and the and the
older cop yeah you know what I mean yeah
because that realized each other that
cop was kind of like he was he wanted to
keep things like above board like and
get Christopher Walken like the right
way like going through legal means he
was the honest one whereas the other
cops were like man we're just gonna
dress up like rival gang members and
just go take them out so I guess they
were equivalents too right mirror images
yeah each other so yeah so when you
think about it like each character had
like a mirror equivalent like on the
other side of the law kind of each other
out right which actually right here to
see it again they might they might have
happened more than once right because
because henchmen were killing it cops
and henchmen were killing each other and
they were kind of like neutralizing each
other yeah
so they're a lot about some symbolism
there yeah I think there was a lot more
going on than yeah you know so this is
yeah this would definitely need a second
watch I feel like
um Danny Rowling said it would be epic
if YouTube reviewed 2005's House of Wax
um I actually would like to do that
that's the one with Paris Hilton right
which um that I remember that being a
good movie I haven't seen it in a long
time but um I remember it being pretty
fun Zach said I saw your shallow grave
video earlier too God I love that movie
I'm so glad that other people have seen
that movie is that because I feel like I
talked about it like before in the 90s
and the 2000s and a lot of people hadn't
seen it even though a lot of people saw
Trainspotting and like Danny Boyle's
other stuff like 28 Days Later and
everything but a lot of people haven't
seen shallow green for some reason and I
really really like if you know that was
one of you and McGregor's like first
movies man he was like a kid in that
um
Chang said they probably ran together
since they were kids it's usually that
way in real life like about the
characters I mean have you reviewed
American Gangster I don't think we have
have we never heard of it I've heard of
it but I've never seen it yeah yeah
that's right I've never seen it
I it's weird because I thought did
somebody send us that no
what am I thinking of
probably thinking of collateral no
[__] what am I thinking of
um Danny Rowling said this film is
better than American Gangster and then
it also says about uh House of Wax yeah
Paris is in it and Loosely based on
waxworks tour strap and the original
House of Wax yeah I'm there I like all
of those kind of like wax museums if a
movie gets sent to us we review it it
goes to it goes to the front of the line
and you can contact Jenny through uh
probably Instagram or her Facebook or
Facebook and uh get the mailing address
and um you can send it to us and
like xanada he sent it through Amazon
Prime it was here like the next day yeah
just give it a different delivery
address on it boom that'll be here oh
and Hugo is here too I don't know if you
sent me um because I asked you for
Hugo's when we're doing the um
yeah yeah so just I gave you the PayPal
and um I just need your mailing address
and we can get it okay put out
um Daniel Rowling said if I sent you the
complete series of Knight Rider would
you review it how wait how long is that
series I don't remember how long it was
on I mean it might take us a while to
get to it but I I I'd be down through it
yeah I'd be down
we're gonna have to
um because Celtic Angel 73 also sent us
um got the base got base Motel so we'll
do a review of that too like whenever
we're finished watching it but like I
said I'm only I'm finished episode 12
and then I have to get into the other
stuff too so I still have like a little
while to go on it should we should we
review baits by season maybe we should
because it would probably be hard
because otherwise it would like take a
long time to kind of yeah maybe we
should do that because we got we're done
with season one yeah yeah I got through
the first disc yeah because each disc
has I think like three or each box has
like three discs in it and it's like one
season so that was like the first 12 and
I got through that so yeah maybe we
should do that and like I said we still
have to do breakfast club because Louise
said it's been a long time that way if
someone sends us an entire series of
something that's a lot of DVDs right and
uh they tend to be more expensive so if
they send us the series and we review
the series they get more than one video
yeah that's probably a good idea and
it'll be easier for us too because
it keeps keeping track of it it's easy
it's much easier to just talk about like
one season at a time rather than like
eight you know 12 15 hours or something
sometimes series isn't sometimes they're
not
consistent season to season some Seasons
better than others so maybe it'd be
better to do it that way Danny Rowling
said Robert England plays The Phantom of
the Opera in a movie studio in an
episode of Knight Rider which is sick I
kind of vaguely remember that because I
remember being kind of excited about it
but it's like I don't remember many
details about it but when you mentioned
it yeah I do remember that but uh but
yeah so
um it's funny because we well Tom and
xanada were talking uh were messaging
back and forth while we were watching
the movie last night and I think that I
think that he thought that maybe I
wouldn't like the movie that you would
like it but then as soon as I saw that
it was able forever I was like oh I
really like Abel Ferreira but I just I
had never seen this one so you know I
was like oh you know she knows him yeah
yeah yeah and so like I said I've only
seen like his old [__] like the most
recent movie of his he's seen I think is
Bad Lieutenant unless he has done one
that I didn't know that was him but like
I said miss 45 is still my favorite but
I've seen that movie a bunch of times
that's like my favorite rape Revenge
movie for sure uh what's tomorrow's a
haunting episode gonna be I think we're
gonna do another season five uh we're
gonna do nightmare in Bridgeport okay
which uh yeah that was the one that I
made the card for that was just like the
next one in the rotation that we haven't
done yet so season five so that's what
we gotta watch uh tonight so that's
what's gonna be on there tomorrow uh or
do you have anything else you would like
to add all right so again thank you very
much Xander for sending us this movie
because we probably wouldn't have got
around to it 10 out of 10 yeah Tom loved
the [__] yeah it's a great movie it's a
great movie super super violent yeah um
really good gangster movie and Chris
dialogue Christopher Walken is always
fun to watch and uh you know great cast
uh I kind of wish Steve Buscemi had been
in it more but I guess this was like an
early yeah you know he's only in a
couple of scenes he's being himself he's
doing he's being his Buscemi yes I love
Stephen shammys
but yeah uh so yeah thank you very much
for sending this this is a great so you
know
um so yeah tomorrow we're gonna be doing
a haunting show at 7 30 p.m Eastern
Standard Time so hopefully you guys can
come by and hang out with us for that so
yeah have a good rest of your weekend
and evening you guys and we will see you
again tomorrow bye